Organisms aren’t immortal.
They eventually die!
So who will make sure that
organisms will still exist in nature?
A simple and efficient system in us makes
sure that the species will be
perpetuated, that is continued in nature even
after we die!
I am referring to
the REPRODUCTION SYSTEM in us!
And not only in us, but the system in all
the animals, plants and the lower
unicellular organisms is extremely important.
It makes sure of the continuation
of species!
So where do we begin?
We need to first understand the process of
reproduction.
It is important for us
to know how exactly this process of reproduction
is carried out.
So let us begin with learning about the PROCESS
OF REPRODUCTION in this
video.
How will we define the process in simplest
words?
Let us divide the word itself!
The word “Re” means again.
And production means making!
So can we define
the process as making something again?
Absolutely!
And what is being made
here?
Of course the organisms!
Now you may say that the new born babies are
not
exactly the same like parents.
So how can we say “Again”?
Well it is not the same organism, but it is
the same species.
A mango tree gives rise to a mango tree.
While a cat gives birth to kitten!
So this is what we mean by Reproduction!
Producing the same species every
time.
So now the next question that pops up in our
mind is that will all the organisms
reproduce in the same manner?
Will unicellular bacteria and huge whales
reproduce in a similar way?
Definitely
not!
If there are several differences in the body
structures and other life processes
of all organisms, then how can the reproduction
pattern be the same?
This gets us the two major types of reproduction
patterns.
The first type is followed by the unicellular
organisms.
Now since it is just one single cell that
carries out all the activities, it is obvious
that even reproduction will be done by the
same tiny creature!
So this type is
the Asexual reproduction.
In this type no specialised cells called sex
cells or
gametes will be produced inside the body.
The single cell will divide in two to
form daughter cells.
And it is done!
On the other hand in case of multi cellular
organisms, the body has specialised
cells called gametes which fuse to form the
new individual.
Such type is
referred to as Sexual Reproduction.
We will learn about the first type that is
Asexual Reproduction in the
upcoming video.